[Musique]
merci Alexandre wiy d'être avec nous
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de loise nouveau sénateur
membre du groupe socialiste on va
évidemment commencer avec vous sur la
nomination de Gabriel Atal à Matignon 34
ans le plus jeune premier ministre vous
êtes de la même génération vous êtes un
tout petit peu plus âgé que lui est-ce
que c'est un un bon signal celui de
l'audace comme il a dit sa nomination
aussi jeune pour moi pour moi la
jeunesse ce n'est n'est qu'un mot vous
sa c'est la formule de de Bourdieu euh
si on regarde la situation moi je
m'intéresse à ce qui se passe dans la
politique et d'ailleurs si on
s'intéresse à la politique de la
jeunesse vous voyez que la situation des
jeunes dans notre pays elle est quand
même en grande difficulté vous avez un
pauvre sur deux qui a moins de 30 ans
vous avez un étudiant sur tris qui
sauteent un repas vous avez un entre
guillemets client des Restos du cœur sur
10 qui est un étudiant vous avez un taux
de chômage des jeunes qui a 18 % donc si
vous voulez dans le symbole c'est
sympathique évidemment je vais pas dire
le contraire mais en revanche dans dans
les faits ça change rien pour la
jeunesse de ce pays d'avoir un premier
ministre jeune s'il met une politique de
vieux si vous voulez ce que je veux dire
ce que vous redoutez ce que je redoute
parce que il y a aucun signal qui montre
un changement de cap un changement de
direction c'est la continuité la plus
pure c'est le macronisme à l'état pure
Gabriel atthal Gabriel atthal il est
issu du parti socialiste il y a été
pendant de nombreuses années il a
notamment travaillé avec Marie sol
Touren est-ce que pour vous il
représente la gauche mais alors moi je
comprends pas cette histoire de issu de
je vous le dis sincèrement a-t-il
sourcillé lors de la réforme des
retraites a-t-il lorsqu'il était
ministre des comptes publiques cherché à
avoir une taxation des super profits à
la hauteur qu'elle devait être a-t-il
pendant le moment de la loi immigration
était de ceux qui avaient quand même une
clause une espèce de clause de
conscience qui apparaissait au niveau du
gouvernement jamais rien donc moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas ce dont il est
issu c'est dans quoi il s'est dissou et
il s'est dissou dans une forme de
libéralisme avec la foi des nouveaux
convertis qu'on qu'on en connaît à peu
donc c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui de
Gabri vous ça laisse pas présager dans
d'un changement de cap vous au Parti
socialiste qui avait beaucoup fusigé une
politique de droite d'Emmanuel Macron
vous n'y voyez pas vous n'espérez pas un
changement de cap absolument pas enfin
il y a aucun indice dans ce qui est
donné aujourd'hui qui laisse espérer
quoi que ce soit et d'ailleurs si vous
voyez il y a le président enfin
président que j'étais j'étais son
conseil régional mais Xavier Bertrand
qui disait hier sur sur une matinale il
a pas d'ailleurs tiré toutes les
conséquences il farait il fallait une
coalition avec la droite puisque sur
tous les textes budgétaires surtout les
textes importants de ce second quinena
la droite et les macronist se sont
retrouvés voilà et donc la droite on
voit bien d'ailleurs salue avec beaucoup
de beaucoup de joie l'arrivée de Gabriel
Atal tout en regrettant le départ de
d'éisabeth borne vous avez le président
reotillot qui dit c'est une bonne chose
vous avezti qui dit il a même fait une
blague il est plus à droite que moi donc
vous avez C cette cette satisfaction
d'une partie de la droite de voir
arriver gabrielal donc non pour la
gauche c'est pas un bon signal du tout
voilà qu'est-ce que vous penseé des des
premiers pas du nouveau Premier ministre
il s'est rendu très vite dans le Pas de
Calais à côté des sinistres et des
inondations hier il était dans dans un
commissariat sur le thème de la sécurité
au côté de Gérald armanin est-ce qu'il
réussit ses premiier pas pour vous al
pour moi c'est important que le premier
ministre montre en effet de la
solidarité avec ce qui se passe dans le
Pas de Calais enfin on est quand même
dans une situation où peut-être demain
dans le pas decalais on aura les
premiers réfugiés climatiqu à
l'intérieur même de l'Hexagone tellement
la situation est difficile tellement en
effet de moin en moin on voit que les
événements climatiques extrêmes se
multiplie donc ça c'est évidemment très
bien très bien de le faire maintenant
c'est pas parce qu'on fait deux
déplacements que ça engage quoi que ce
soit sur la politique qu'on va qu'on va
mener donc oui c'est c'est bien que
Gabriel Atal montre du mouvement mais
pour lui-même mais en soit ça ça fait
pas tourner le pays tout ça il tarde à
former son gouvernement est-ce que vous
attendez quelque chose de ce nouveau
gouvernement non mais ce que je crains
c'est que ce
soit le dernier carré des fidèles autour
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est fini le temps de
l'ouverture vers même la société civile
on sent même dans les noms qui sont
presscenti et qui et qui circule c'est
vraiment ce qu'il reste autour du du
macronisme dans sa version dans sa
version initiale donc on est dans un
gouvernement qui va être à la portion
congrue de ce point de vuel est-ce que
vous souhaitez que que gabrielal
s'exprime très rapidement devant le
Parlement et est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il y ait un vote qu'il se soumett à
un vote je pense qu'il faut qu'il
demande la confiance à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est la tradition c'est la
tradition dans ce payer et puis ça lui
permettra de faire un discours de
politique de politique générale donc
évidemment qu'il faut qu'il qu'il faut
qu'il le fasse mais vous voyez on est là
psassociera une motion de censure s'il
ne fait pas ça je ce sera au députés
dans ce sera au députés d'en décider
évidemment et c'est la tradition qu'il
le fasse bien évidemment parce que nous
ne sommes c'est la manière pour
l'opposition de dire qu'elle ne soutient
pas la politique du du gouvernement mais
je vais vous dire le le péché originel
de tout ça c'est quoi c'est qu'en 2022
Emmanuel Macron n'a jamais accepté
l'assemblée que lui avait donné les
Français s'il l'avait accepté il aurait
construit la coalition avec la droit
dont on parlait il y a quelques instants
pourquoi ne le fait-il pas parce que ça
voudrait dire actter acter le fait que
le dépassement macronistme nétait le
geste initial du macronistme n'existe
plus et c'est ça qu'il se refuse à faire
et c'est pour ça que le pays va can à
con parce qu'il n'assume pas il n'assume
pas le fait d'être en coalition de fait
avec la droite parlementaire lors de sa
passation de pouvoir il s'est adressé
aux oppositions il a dit on sera pas
toujours d'accord il y aura du débat
mais je vous promets d'être toujours à
l'écoute Olivier fort avait boycotté les
dernières rencontres de saint-demi avec
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que là si Gabriel
Atal le convit il ira B en fait Olivier
fort il boycotte les les choses où il a
l'impression d'être un faire valoir si
vous voulez s'il s'il y a des
possibilités de travailler sur des
sujets et d'ailleurs le parti socialiste
a voté un certain nombre de lois dans
dans ce quinquena lorsqu'il considérait
que c'était une bonne chose donc s'il y
a des espaces de travail pour essayer de
faire avancer des sujets nous on n
jamais ennemi des intérêts du pays donc
s'il y a des choses à faire on le fera
pour le pays bien évidemment mais on
nira pas faire le pot de fleur ou bien
le faire valoir dans des réunions ça ça
n'existe pas ça ne sert à rien gabrielal
a dit qu'il réunirait très vite les
forces vives dont les les élus de
l'opposition on imagine il faut y aller
du coup mais il faut voir l'ordre du
jour il faut voir ce qui est proposé
comme cadre de travail il faut voir si
c'est juste une 1è opération de
communication ou c'est quelque chose de
plus sérieux on nous avait quand même
promis en janvier un grand rendez-vous
avec la nation c'est un petit remanement
entre amis voilà pour vous c'est ça le
rendez-vous vous attendez pas autre
chose ah bah on va voir mais pour
l'instant on nous avait dit le 8 janvier
donc voilz la date est déjà dépassé on
va continuer à parler de Gabriel hatal
on va parler d'économie vous êtes
professeur vous d'économie sujet sur
lequel Gabriel hatthal notamment est
attendu alors que Bruno LEM l'a rappelé
en début de semaine il va falloir
trouver des économies on fait le point
avec Quentin calm qui
[Musique]
rejoint bonjour Quentin bonjour Rian
bonjour Quentin dans le remanimement qui
se profile certains ministres pourraient
conserver leur portefeuille ministériel
à l'image de Bruno Leem voilà Bruno
leemire qui pourrait conserver
effectivement Bercy sauf coup de théâtre
majeur lundi il présentait ses vœux aux
acteurs économiques quand d'autres
ministres d'ailleurs avaient préféré
reporter he cette séance de vœux comme
un certain Gabriel hatal l'undi c'était
sans doute bien vu d'avoir reporté cette
séance de vœux mais on peut le dire que
ce n'était pas euphorique l'ambiance
acie lundi lors de cette séance des vœux
le premier risque économique dans le
monde a dit Bruno Le Maire et bien c'est
d'abord un risque géopolitique avec le
retour de la guerre dans le monde et sur
le territoire européen a dit le ministre
il a encore un peu plus refroidi la
salle avec un point sur la situation
budgétaire du pays écoutez Bruno Le
Maire je ne voudrais surtout pas gâcher
l'ambiance chalureuse de cette cérémonie
de vœux qui me va droite au cœur mais je
rappelle que nous devons trouver au
minimum au minimum 12 milliards d'euros
d'économie pour
2025 appelons donc un chat un chat en
matière de finances publiqu le plus dur
est devant nous alà Bruno Le Maire qui a
également évoqué l'objectif du plein
emploi avec une phrase très importante
dans son discours écoutez à nouveau le
ministre de l'Économie le plein emploi
il est à 5 %. deux points nous sépare de
cet objectif cet objectif nous devons
tout faire pour l'atteindre et je le
redis il ne pourra pas être atteint à
modèle social constant emploi des plus
de 55 ans logement complexité des
prestations sociales formation lycée
professionnel RSA tous ces sujets le
président de la République et la
première ministre ont eu le courage de
les mettre sur la table et bien
maintenant il faut aller au bout de
notre réflexion trancher prendre des
décisions pour pouvoir financer ce
modèle social par le plein emploi avec
une seule volonté faire revenir au
travail le plus grand nombre de
personnes Alexandre une réaction à cette
déclaration cet objectif du plein emploi
ne pourra pas être atteint à modèle
social constant qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous évoque bah l'objectif du plein
d'emploi et tout le monde le partage et
d'ailleurs les prévisionnistes sont
plutôt inquiet pour ce qui est de
l'année 2020 24 on annonce aujourd'hui
on est à 7,2 % de chômage on annonce 7,9
% de chômage à à la fin de l'année je
suis absolument pas d'accord évidemment
avec ce qui vient d'être dit et
d'ailleurs en fait la réalité c'est que
la politique qui est aujourd'hui menée
est déjà une politique qui atteint
gravement notre modèle social
aujourd'hui on est dans cette paradoxe
où on crée de l'emploi et de la pauvreté
en même temps vous avez aujourd'hui dans
ce pays 9,1 millions de pauvres depuis
le lancement de la statistique Inc en 96
en 1996 vous m'entendez bien il n'y a
jamais eu autant de pauvres dans ce pays
donc en même temps qu'il se gargarise de
créer de l'emploi il crée des pauves
c'est qu'il crée des travailleurs
pauvres donc le la question c'est pas le
modèle social la question c'est le
modèle économique et quand je l'entends
dire il faut 12 milliards de trouver 12
milliards d'économies de dépenses
supplémentaires ça fait des années moi
vous savez je l'appelle le véau de ber
ça fait des années qu'il mène la même
politique la même politique c'est quoi
c'est une politique de l'offre mais
jusqu'au bout c'està-dire que chaque
année on remet une pièce dans la baisse
de la fiscalité des entreprises au point
que les entreprises françaises qui
avaient il y a un certain temps un
problème de marge on aujourd'hui des
marges exceptionnelles et au lieu au
lieu de venir se dire que maintenant il
faut qu'on mette un coup de pouce côté
deande au lieu de se dire qu'on va aller
travailler sur l'économie de l'essentiel
c'est la construction baisse de 26 % des
mises en chantier sur 1 an et des permis
de construire au lieu de se dire tout ça
et ben il balayent cela sur l'hôtel de
sacrifice du modèle social in sur les
baisses DEP dépenses publiqu mais sur le
modèle social est-ce qu'il faut réformer
notre modèle social pour le sauver c'est
la question que pose BR mais si vous
voulez si ce qu'on appelle former le
modèle social c'est toujours retrancher
des droits au salariés et ben c'est pas
ça qui qui consiste à sauver le modèle
social en fait c'est c'est le détruire
que ENF on détruit pas un malade en le
tuant c'est ça c'est ça le sujet donc
non aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire il faut rien toucher ou il faut
réform personne ne dit qu'il faut rien
toucher la question c'est je prends
l'exemple que donnait Bruno le parce que
c'est celui sur lequel il travaille en
ce moment du travail des seniors
d'accord aujourd'hui le travail de
seniors c'est pas un problème de de gens
qui veulent qui veulent plus travailler
c'est le problème de comment les
entreprises gardent les seniors en
activité donc l'idée de les punir en
baissant je je finis là-dessus en
baissant en baissant leurs d'accord en
baissant leurs allocations ça crée quoi
juste de la pauvreté parce que vous
rentrez plus vite dans les minimas
sociaux au lieu d'être au chômage donc
vous êtes encore moins protégé
financièrement et la pauvreté continuera
d'augmenter or le président de la
République a dit dans ses vœux qu'il
voulait lutter contre la pauvreté
première nouvelle vu ce qui se passe
depuis 5 ans dans le pays on a un des
taux d'emploi des seniors les plus
flbles de la zone euro effectivement
depuis fin novembre pour lutter contre
et bien ce phénomène le ministre de
l'économie a évoqué l'idée de réduire
les indemnités chômage pour les seniors
les partenaires sociaux sont en train de
négocier ils sont ils sont très
sceptiques vous le dites clairement au
gouvernement c'est une ligne rouge mais
évidemment évidemment vous prenez les
gens qui sont le plus en difficulté face
à l'emploi vous l'avez dit c'est la
situation des personnes de de plus de 55
ans par rapport
au du travail aller sur marché du
travail mais vous croyez vraiment que
enfin c'est quoi la vision que que les
que le gouvernement a des Français il
croit que contrairement aux autres pays
les Français quand ils arrivent à 55 ans
il ne rêvent que d'une chose c'est de se
faire virer de leur boîte mais c'est
c'est c'est n'importe quoi de penser ça
la question est le travail d'ailleurs il
y a une partie des réflexions qui est
sur des 45è des d'autres modalités qui
peuvent être intéressantes mais se dire
que juste on va aller couper dans les on
va aller couper dans les les les
indemnisations chômage qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce qui va se passer vous allezer
avoir des gens qui vont basculer bah
vers les minimas sociaux vous allez vers
le RS ça é aussi certaines entreprise
parce que vous le savez il y a la
tentation chez certaines entreprises de
de mettre ses seiors en retraite
anticipé et et de s'en débarrasser entre
guillemets plus vite est-ce que la
réforme des règles n'évitera pas ça
aussi et permettra un maintien moi moi
je pense que la réforme des des règles
va créer des pauvres de récrer des
personnes âgées pauvres dans notre pays
et ça c'est pas une solution voilà
Quentin Bruno Le Maire a déjà évoqué
deux futurs textes de loi qui arriveront
dans les premiers mois de 2024 voilà il
a déjà parlé effectivement dans ce
discours des vœux de deux prochains
projets de loi qu'il va présenter
effectivement il a commencé en évoquant
les bonnes nouvelles pour la France en
matière d' investissement étrangers nous
avons su tirer le plein parti du brexit
a-t-il dit pour attirer à Paris les plus
grands établissements financiers de la
planète pour enfoncer le clou il annonce
ainsi une loi sur l'attractivité
financière de la France elle sera
présentée au Parlement au printemps 2024
deuxème sujet que vous voyez d'ailleurs
sur cette animation et bien le
gouvernement entend permettre de geler
les avoirs des trafiquant comme c'est
possible pour les terroristes c'est la
deuxème annonce de son discours que dire
des pers persective présentée par Bruno
LEM notamment on va revenir au début de
cette chronique sur la question de la de
la dépense publique et de la réduction
de cette dépense publique va rentrer
dans le dur en 2024 vous le pensez ah
mais en tout cas ils ont clairement
annoncé la couleur que 2025 serait une
année douloureuse du point de vue de de
la dépense publique mais vous savez
quand on est dans un moment de
difficulté économique comme l'on vit
aujourd'hui avec une croissance qui est
à ton faible quand vous touchez à la
dépense publique vous touchez à des
dépenses essentielles qui permettent de
de soutenir la croissance donc
évidemment que c'est un mauvais choix
quand on voit le niveau de réduction
d'impôt il a d'autres solutions en fait
vous avez des solutions côté recettes ou
côté dépense cette majorité refuse
toutes les solutions qu'on lui propose
côté recette parce qu'on a un taux de
prélèvement qui est très fort sur les
entreprises mais qui est en réduction
continue
constante et l'effort aujourd'hui il est
porté principalement par les ménages il
est porté vous avez baissé l' vous avez
supprimé les impôts de production vous
êtes en train de supprimer les impôts de
production au bout d'un moment ça suffit
regardez les taux de marge des
entreprises françaises regardez
l'inflation aujourd'hui l'inflation elle
est de non plus à des coûts trop trop
élevés mais elle est d au fait que les
entreprises pratiquent des marges sur
les prix qui ont augmenté donc vous
voyez les entreprises françaises ne sont
pas en difficulté ne sont pas en
difficulté c'est faux de présenter les
choses comme ça et donc aujourd'hui le
problème c'est de protéger les Français
on est dans un moment où on doit
protéger les Français et donc ça
implique de faire des choix et le choix
si on doit transférer 12 milliards
d'impôts aux entreprises pour protéger
les Français il faut le faire un mot
là-dessus parce qu'on connait pas la
composition du gouvernement mais on a
appris hier que Emmanuel moulin l'actuel
directeur du Trésor allait être le
directeur de cabinet de Gabriel hatal
est-ce que c'est un proche de Bruno
leemer est-ce que vous y voyez le signe
d'une rigueur budgétaire à venir en fait
il ne s'en cache pas de la rigueur
budgétaire il il le dit je vous le dis
au bamot il va falloir trouver 12 12
milliards d'euros donc oui le fait que
ce soit ce profil de directeur de
cabinet qui a était choisi bah c'est
c'est en effet un signal de d' enfin ce
n ce n'est pas pour rien qu'il
choisissent profil après vous savez
quand on choisit ses collaborateurs on
choisit des gens avec qui on se sent à
l'aise de travailler il y a plein
d'autres critères qui rentrent en en
compte je sais pas s'il faut voir des
signaux partout mais mais mais en effet
en tout cas il y aura quelqu'un qui aura
un œil sur les comptes du côté de
matigon avec ce profil ouis on le disait
donc deux textes qui vont arriver au
Parlement une loi sur l'attractivité
financière de la France et une deuxième
projet de loi sur et bien
effectivement les trafics de stupéfiants
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de ce
programme alors je sur la question de
l'attractivité financière je connais pas
le détail du texte évidemment pu
puisqu'il n'existe pas en revanche ce
que je sais c'est que si la logique
c'est la même que celle de l'amendement
FIFA c'est-à-dire de faire un cadre
d'exception pour permettre l'arrivée de
certains acteurs et
cetera exactement retoqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc qui qui n'aura pas
lieu alors que tout le Sénat à
l'unanimité lui avait dit c'est une
mauvaise idée de faire ce type
d'exemption etervé avec le 493
exactement si si ce type si
l'attractivité financière elle se paye
du fait de transformer ce pays en un
paradis fiscal c'est pas possible voilà
c'est pas possible c'est pas souhaitable
et sur la question de des de la lutte
contre les stupéfiants ben évidemment
que que c'est une bonne chose de
s'attaquer à à ce type de à ce type de
sujet mais encore une fois vous me
demandez de commenter quelque chose un
petit peu dans le vide parce que j'ai
pas de texte sous les yeux et et c'est
pas évident de vous répondre quoisolent
on verra ça dans les prochains mois oui
je reviens dans le club on parlera
effectivement et bien de la gauche qui
demande à pouvoir voter après le
discours de politique générale qui va
intervenir bientôt dans les prochains
jour de Gabriel àal on parle de tout ça
dans un peu plus d'une demi-heure avec
vous Quentin à tout à l'heure on va voir
l'actualité dans votre département de
Loise pour ça on retrouve Jean-Marc
chevaucher rédacteur en chef adjoint au
Courrier Picard bonjour Jean-Marc merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Jean-Marc on
le disait Alexandre wiisy est tout
nouveau sénateur é Luu en septembre
dernier vous souhaaitiez revenir
là-dessus
oui monsieur wiisille bonjour à vous
vous êtes sénateur depuis septembre en
effet vous avez succédé à Laurence
rosignol qui n'a pas été choisi par les
militants PS de l'ISE comme vous l'avait
été elle est partie se faire élire dans
le Val de Marne ma question est toute
simple vous avez reçu ses vœux pour
cette nouvelle année euh je je n'ai pas
encore reçu ses vœux mais je je je je je
vois ce qu'il y a derrière derrière
votre question non moi écoutez dans
l'Oise il y a un choix qui a été fait
par les militants et les élus parce
qu'il pensaient que c'était le bon choix
mais moi je suis heureux que et
d'ailleurs dès dès l'annonce de ce choix
la Fédération a immédiatement communiqué
en disant qu'on souhaitait que Laurence
puisse continuer ses combats on est
heureux qu'elle le fasse ici au Sénat où
elle a une parole utile et qui porte
loin
voilà Jean-Marc vous avez votre
réponse vous avez eu votre réponse super
merci Jean-Marc merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous la une du Courrier Picard
dans son édition de looise ce matin si
vous voulez nous en nous en dire un
petit mot Jean-Marc chevaucher on
s'engage contre la précarité
énergétique oui alors ça c'est c'est
vrai que c'est la c'est la Une de looise
euh il y a à l'intérieur du du journal
un autre dossier qui nous tient à cœur
ce sont les
féminicides qui ont eu lieu encore cette
année en Picardie alors cette fois c'est
c'est paloise qui en 2023 n'a pas été
frappé par ce drame comme l'ont été les
autres départements mais la somme est
dans le peloton de tête des départements
français et évidemment ça ne réjouit
personne merci Jean-Marc c'est allire
aujourd'hui dans le courrier Picard
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on
va parler des des européennes c'est la
prochaine échéance électorale Alexandre
wiisy vous travaillez là-dessus pour le
Parti socialiste est-ce que la
nomination de Gabriel hatal et pour vous
la meilleure arme enti rassemblement
national en vu de cette élection non je
crois pas je pense que la meilleure arme
elle s'appelle raphaë glxman mais ça
vous surprendra pas tout simplement
parce qu'en fait qui pressenti pour être
tête de liste place publique et Parti
socialiste exactement qui pressentit
pour
diriger pour conduire pour conduire
cette liste je pense que c'est la
meilleure arme parce qu'en fait Gabriel
Atal c'est la tentative c'est l'
tentative pour essayer de maquiller le
retour des clivages or on le voit sur
tous les grands sujets sur tous les
grands dossiers les clivages
réapparaissent au point que sur
immigration cette majorité s'est
fracturée et donc on a besoin de de
clarté dans l'élection européenne et
Raphaël Luxman c'est l'antithèse de
Jordan Bardella à tout point de vue sur
les droits humains sur l'Ukraine par
rapport à la Russie sur tous les grands
thèmes qu'il porte et donc je pense que
la meilleure arme c'est Raphaël Luxman
parce que au niveau européen vous savez
le débat n'est pas comme froco
franco-français le grand groupe au
niveau européen c'est le groupe du Parti
socialiste européen et donc si vous
voulez peser sur le destin de l'Europe
entre un avenir conservateur et un
avenir de progrès et ben le choix c'est
Raphaël Luxman c'est pas le le petit
groupe parlementaire constitue la
majorité présidentielle qui du sens au
niveau euréen du pourqui pourquoi tant
tarder à le désigner officiellement on
tarde pas on a juste des processus vous
savez on est dans un parti profondément
démocratique au Parti socialiste on est
dans le moment où nous-mêmes nous
choisissons nos candidats nous faisons
émerger des candidatures il y a quand
même une génération fort qui s'est
installée au sein du Parti socialiste et
je pense que la liste sera aussi le
reflet de de de cela et et et du coup
c'est c'est juste qu'on est en train de
travailler à tout ça voilà et et
d'ailleurs Olivier fort a dit je crois
dans une matinale il y a pas si
longtemps il y a pas vraiment de
suspense voilà il y a pas vraiment de
suspense sur le fait que on est parti
pour travailler ensemble mais est-ce que
vous ne craignez pas que cette élection
se résume désormais un duel à tal
Bardella je crois pas je crois que les
gens ont envie de c'est une élection où
les le scrutin national ne pèse pas à
100 % sinon les vers n'uraient pas fait
la percée qu'ils avaient pu faire la
dernière fois je crois que les gens ont
envie de voter sur tout simplement ce
qui est l'avenir de l'Europe ça devient
un objet politique qui les concerne dont
il voit l'utilité au jour le jour on
pensait que la paix était aussi
naturelle que l'air qu'on respire on
voit qu'à quelques milliers de
kilomètres de chez nous il y a deux
guerres au Levant et en Ukraine donc
tout ça évidemment crée un contexte
favorable au débat européen à la
profondeur du débat européen quel est
votre objectif c'est quoi c'est d'être
en test des listes de gauche ah je pense
qu'on peut se donner on peut se donner
les les meilleurs objectifs du monde
vous savez moi je suis pas trop à
raisonn par par Objectif j'ai pas vous
donner un chiffre ça aurait pas vraiment
de sens en fait mais sans chiffre quel
est votre objectif l'objectif c'est de
faire basculer l'Europe voilà de faire
basculer donc ça ne se passe pas qu'en
France l'objectif c'est de contribuer
d'être à être de ceux qui font basculer
l'Europe vers une option progressiste
d'éviter la contagion qu'on observe
parfois des idées d'extrême droite sur
différentes plaques européennes je sais
pas si vous avez vu quand même ce qui
s'est passé dans la rue à Rome il y a
quelques quelques quelques jours avec
des salut des salut nazis enfin tout
tout tout ça évidemment est mauvais dans
dans l'air du temps donc nous il faut
qu'on arrive à contrarier ça par une
autre vision de l'Europe qui assume à la
fois d'être un objet de de puissance
dans le monde mais qui assume un modèle
social exigeant qui assume une certaine
vision de l'économie une certaine vision
du partage de l'entraide c'est ça qu'on
veut porter dans cette dans cette
élection alors c'est une élection
européenne évidemment mais difficile
d'imaginer qu'elle n'aura aucun impact
sur le plan national est-ce qu'il y a
pas au Parti socialiste une volonté en
tout cas un espoir d'arriver en tête des
listes de gauche et de redéciiner la
Nupe en peu en affaiblissant la France
insoumise non il y a en fait je moi je
suis pour alors là je vous le dis très
simplement pour moi on doit pas faire de
campagne négative voilà ça doit pas être
la liste gluxman qui tape sur la liste
de Manon auri et la liste de Marie
toussin pour moi ce sont tous des gens
les trois dont on parle sont des gens
extrêmement valables le sujet il est pas
celui-là le sujet il faut que je fin je
finis juste là-dessus le sujet il faut
que l'ensemble des listes de gauche
parce que c'est une élection la
proportionnelle ce n'est pas la même
logique qu'un scrutin uninominal fin à
deux tours l'ensemble gauche fasse le
plus grand score possible parce que si
la gauche dans son ensemble fait un très
large score évidemment je seraai heureux
qu'on arrive en Têt des listes de gauche
parce que évidemment je soutiens la
candidature de Raphael Luxman mais plus
on fera un large score plus on incarnera
l'alternative au au macronis par rapport
à l'extrême droite mais si vous voulez
pas de campagne négative quand vous
entendez manuel bonpard qui sera qui
sera à votre place dans dans quelques
secondes qui dit que il y a de
l'irresponsabilité qui serait
irresponsable de ne pas avoir que laanup
ne soit pas en capacité d'avoir une
liste commune qu'est-ce que vous dites
de ça non ce qui serait irresponsable
c'est de faire une campagne négative les
uns contre les autres ça ce serait
irresponsable si tout le monde fait
valoir sa proposition fait valoir aussi
ses nuances le débat il gagne il y a
rien de négatif là-dedans ce qu'il faut
en revanche c'est que après ce moment
qu' a un moment de séparation on prépare
soigneusement soigneusement ce qui va
arriver en 2027 parce que là en revanche
le mode de scrutin appelle l'unité
appelle le travail commun appelle le
dépassement de de de de nos différences
et c'est ça qu'il faut configuré est-ce
que ça veut dire que le moratoire qui
est en cours actuellement puisque le le
PS a suspendu sa participation à la nuub
va durer jusqu'aux européenes bah ça
veut dire le le moratoire vous sais je
crois que Boris valallot qui est
président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée et Olivier fort ont donné un
peu le modus opérandi il faut retrouver
des règles de entre guillemets de vie de
vie de vie commune qui fonctionnent donc
il faut TR donc si bah ça veut dire que
il faut que dans la manière dont on
s'exprime les uns avec les autres on
accepte que le choix de l'un n'engage
pas l'autre et que donc si l'autre ne
fait pas exactement le même choix que
nous c'est pas parce qu'il est méchant
ou parce que c'est un ennemi mais parce
que juste il y a des nuances entre nous
tout ça il faut réussir à le recadrer
parce que bah les gens les uns et les
autres il y a pas que le Parti
socialiste visiblement ne ne se
sentaient plus tout à fait à l'aise dans
la manière dont les choses
fonctionnaient voilà mais ce qui est la
spécificité quand même d'Olivier fort et
de cette majorité c'est que nous n'avons
jamais perdu la vision et l'objectif de
l'unité en 2027 parce que nous voyons la
responsabilité historique qui a devant
nous avec Marine Le Pen merci merci
Alexandre on va parler dans quelques
instants avec Manuel bonp merci merci
d'avoir été notre invité dans